Rowdy Roddy Piper I did this movie that
was not good and he was like you know he
had a scene in the movie and he came to
the premiere with his kids and he no one
told him he wasn't in the mood that's
messed up and I was like and afterwards
like he goes hey man you're funny and I
go hey I can't believe your stuff wasn't
in there he's like yeah bud he was so
cool he taught me the sleeper hold yeah
I go I I said hey look does the sleeper
hold really work rowdy rowdy Piper
he looked at me and goes come here I'm
going to show you something
anyway you just want to grab it right
here grab your arm around the neck the
other arm goes this way and I'm going to
pull here or something and I just was I
was out and he caught me yeah and he
goes now you're gonna do it to me oh I
can't I can't hold you up he goes no
you'll be all right just make sure I
don't fall hit the ground anybody could
do the sleeper hold
did you make him pass out and I made him
pass out because he showed me how to do
and he goes like this and like whoa
yeah see there